[Applause]
you wit that way most west hundred
meters no weapon easy kill
huh no plane watch the drop cookies a
bigger gun
oh [ __ ] that's real close let's get it
that's a death trap we haven't seen
anyone out here for hours we're probably
the only ones left I mean the games
still going right then there's other
people left yeah cuz they're watching
the crate look I don't even have a gun
you freaking frying pan if we don't get
what's in that crate we're gettin killed
by the guys who do
[Music]
what do you think we get if we win
probably a million dollars or something
be great you know would be great
not dying how about not dying and a
million bucks you cross that field
you're gonna get shocked we'll just
crawl no we'll see you I can see you
guys somebody shoots at us shoot at them
yeah I can do that all right
[Music]
[Applause]
how do you open it
[Music]
[Applause]
surprise [ __ ]
[Music]
you forgot to write did it
guy
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Music]
ha
pack it help take the edge off
[Music]
you go kill the guy with the fried dough
sit
[Music]
what
[Applause]
hmm you guys forgot the main weapon
wrench oh so so Tim's not happy about it
so I don't know where that can scope is
they forgot a radio so I have no idea
what's going on over there right now
the lady is you've done by pelvic 12
times